à bord de ce bateau de secours espagnols
les corps de 24 migrants retrouvé au
large des îles canaries
des personnes originaires d'afrique
subsaharienne vraisemblablement morte de
faim et de soif sur leur fragile
embarcation
voguant sur les eaux agitées de l'océan
atlantique seules trois personnes ont
survécu
très affaibli elles ont expliqué aux
autorités espagnoles avoir passé 22
jours en mer un drame qui vient
s'ajouter à une longue liste de faits
similaires l'an dernier plus de 23000
migrantes atteint l'archipel des
canaries un chiffre multiplié par huit
en un an selon les ong caminando
frontera somme en 1850 et une personnes
sont mortes en 2020 dans des tentatives
pour atteindre l'archipel espagnol
c'est dans ce contexte avec un sens du
timing déconcertant que bruxelles a
dévoilé un plan pour le retour des
déboutés du droit d'asile vers leur pays
d'origine
était-ce note secrète ce n'est pas un
secret que l'union européenne n'a pas
particulièrement réussies en matière de
retour jusqu'ici en 2019
environ 500 mille personnes ont reçu
l'injonction de partir et seulement 142
mille sont réellement reparti cela veut
dire que nous parvenons à peine à nous
occuper d'un tiers de ce qu'il devrait
partir parmi les pistes exposé celle
d'une coopération renforcée entre
l'union européenne et les pays d'origine
des migrants ou encore l'élargissement
des prérogatives accordées à l' agence
frontex une agence plongé dans la
controverse
accusé notamment d' expulsion illégale
et dans une enquête de plusieurs médias
européens dont libération on découvre
aussi les liens ambigus et parfois
illégaux entre l' agence européenne et
les garde-côtes libyens
nous avons pu reconstruire avec
précision le déroulement de 94 tentative
de traversée qui ont eu lieu entre
janvier 2020 et mars 2021 en
méditerranée centrale pour 56 k les
garde-côtes libyens ont finalement
intercepté les bateaux de migrants avant
de les ramener à tripoli pour 20
situation un avion de frontex a été
aperçu à proximité de la scène du
naufrage
avant même l'intervention des
garde-côtes récupérés par les autorités
libyennes ces migrants sont ensuite
placés dans des conditions de vie
dramatiques
ou des faits de torture ont été
dévoilées une atteinte aux droits de
l'homme qui ne fait que renforcer la
détermination des candidats à la
traversée
ils sont nombreux à tenter le voyage
malgré les risques encourus